whether you getting a useful result out
of on this process or not depends very
much on what kind of values you pick up
okay so you saw before I picked these
and I kind of gave you an explanation as
to why but it wasn't like I mean it
wasn't very in-depth explanation you
kind of just trusted that they would be
useful okay
turned out they were now what values
should we put in here for starters what
kinds of values am I going to put in it
do you remember what I've got here right
in this middle column because I'm going
to take sign of all of these in the next
step right from here to here this called
them is sine of this column right so
since I'm taking side of this column
I've you know ciders with angles right
so I wanted sine of angles in this
column make sense so I'm doing the same
things here right being that I've got X
all of these values I'm about to take
the sign on these values okay I'm going
to think of some angles in here okay so
how far did you go back what kinds of
values did you pick - 5.6 did anyone
start further back why it was high now
let me suggest right that you should
have known to go further back because
why I didn't go further back here why
not have - two - three - four and so on
as values to test out yeah it's it's
once again undefined here it just gets
worse and worse and worse because we're
blocked in between minus 1 and 1
right but being that sign it can take
any angles you like they can be huge
like the domain of sine is all realized
ok so how far should we go back I'm
going to go back to super fine okay I'm
gonna go back into five right I'm gonna
be enough to demonstrate a pattern okay
um what add other values or I'll take oh
that's 2 pi you know maybe 3 PI on - hi
- pile on soon as we start to get in
closer we can take some smaller angles
because we do the exact values for those
right so for example we go - point 4 0 4
- so I'm going to get hopefully some
symmetry here ok right now hopefully we
know this well enough by now and I'm not
modifying sign in any way right so it's
just standard old vanilla unchanged sign
ok
what's sine of minus 2 pi q tell me you
head to 0 right okay - we climb -
where's that that's now hold on one
second
okay so minus 3.2 is here right so so
that is one yes minus PI that value
there so I'm back to zero okay - plan -
where's that that's here right so minus
one minus PI and four so I've gone
halfway in here what's that exact value
- 100 - okay sine of zero is still zero
okay what happens here
it's an odd function right it's an odd
function social I should expect all of
these to just get reversed around so I'm
going to get 1 0 minus 1 and 0 that okay
yeah all right now what happens when you
take sine inverse of these values well
what do you what do you get of something
when you put inside of a zero to your
calculator what do you get zero sine
inverse of 1 now you stopped right
you're like hmm okay I've done I've done
two values I've done two values and I
can already see there's some serious
changes happening okay so the first
three graphs I saw told me that it was
just equal to X and it just went forever
okay but it doesn't take that many
values to see okay something's breaking
quite seriously okay you come back to
zero zero okay sine inverse of minus one
what's that
Kiko Calero what's say inverse of minus
R sine inverse of minus one
why - what's my power - it's the angle
it's the angle within the domain of sine
inverse when you take sine of it it will
give you lifetime sine of this does take
it out okay seiyya T inverse of minus
one over two I'll save you some time
okay now this is interesting right I
started off by saying this doesn't look
anything like you know sine inverse of
sine X doesn't look anything like X but
now it's starting to well this one does
it okay so this one not not nice but now
in here we are right these are equal to
each other this is equal to this okay
and you can predict right sine inverse
of 0 is 0 right so that's also the same
okay now before I go any further let's
actually draw this out okay
what values am I going to get well yes
sorry which have I gone oh no oh wait
can you see that you see the graph had a
curious channel now yeah very much oh
it's just it was just not yeah that's ok
sir
all right now just like here I'm going
to put my values in it okay so we go
what I got minus 2 pi minus 3 miles is
this graph in a work unit or one - pi -
plan - and then I have my interval so -
bhai on four okay
now when I went from here to here one
again I got zero minus 3.2 the value I
got was PI R 2 so I'm going I'm going up
now all right now I'm going to keep this
one to one so it's like a square grid if
you like so if that's quite - there okay
here's my value
yes or the next one I have minus PI zero
yeah
then - time - that was the same value
right
Shino so it's coming down to here - plan
for same day I should really have
another color intuition it's getting a
bit creepy
okay and we had zero right now what's
this starting to look like fine yeah
sorry oh look a bit sauce right now you
can test out a few more values but um
you know it's it's linear right it's
linear as as these change I could have
put in more values in here right if I
had say minus PI over 3 which would be
in between here okay - plan three is
going to map to - pound three so there
are no curves here right but if I
continue this pattern it's going to
canter here now I'm guessing he'll stop
why why might we guess that it might
stop
that's that is what happened oh he are
right but more than that I guess also
doing that yeah that's true well
actually
okay it is what I was thinking about as
well as that the domain restriction here
all of these values right so I'm taking
sine inverse what did we say was the
range of sine inverse am I go back to
table from yesterday
exactly I know I have no Y here but you
get the idea right so therefore all the
values that this should give us should
always be between minus PI to the power
two okay
so that means I'm walked in here right
so that would be PI on - okay
and since I'm locked in what's it going
to do it's going to come back down I'm
going to get this kind of shape okay so
some of you said it's kind of like a
sine curve but it's not curved it's
jagged and 25 um yeah so it's it's how
are we going to how we're going to
describe it the way we describe sine a
sine inverse this is sine inverse of
sine okay well I can start off in much
the same way can I say versus sine is
equal to X in a certain domain what's
the domain
yeah good jump just in that little spot
there for okay now how do you describe
the rest of it how do you describe the
rest of it hmm hmm is right now you can
you can you can use that you can take
you know Jaguar you think about it for a
minute okay
um at the actually at the end of the day
probably I'm gonna ask you what did you
come up with I think there's got to be
at least two or three different ways to
describe it just like here we said you
know well it doesn't exist that's under
fun no problems right well how are you
gonna describe this what's that equal to
and what about this one right how are
you going to wear that how can we
geometrically describe it okay kind of
all right now um I walked it through
this okay and then I sort of let you
flan around and walk you through that I
want you to do the same for can you
guess okay so let's do let's do cars and
positive us cause of causing us then
let's do cos inverse of course now by
the way before you actually start
testing any values right I think having
gone through this process you ought to
be able to make some educated guesses
before you actually start doing this to
save you a bit of work okay so what I
want you to do before you start
calculating values okay just just make a
make a hypothesis okay think I reckon I
reckon it's going to look something like
this you know write something like this
and if it's totally wrong that's fine
okay I just want to see if you can
practice your mental chops rather and
just go through it - Leonardo no it
looks like this because because it does
okay
and then if you're surprised then
that'll be something that we can pursue
okay and again for this you know we've
seen that something different happens
when you stop the side in sine inverse
so we would expect the causing fuzziness
to do the same I'm probably just going
to give you ten in tammy's because by
that time you
sick of it okay so you probably going to
do that on to the end of the lesson but
in period seven seven I'll show you the
answers okay but I want you have to go
yeah keep going
it keeps going and the reason it keeps
going it's a bit it's sort of it's kind
of misleading to have arrows isn't it
because arrows kind of just it suggests
it just goes and goes and goes but it
has this same kind of its periodic okay
and the reason why think about it this
way right why is this undefined for
certain values okay and the answer is
because this is under fire for certain
that this is the crucial part it's the
middle part that's important okay just
like this is undefined for certain
values because this is this graph is
periodic just like this is you see that
it's the middle part that's definitive
okay
so yes it keeps going forever it keeps
on bouncing up and down just like sine
does